>> Lola Pyne: Hello and welcome
to our program honoring
young writers of the A Book
That Shaped Me summer
writing contest.
I'm Lola Pyne.
And I work in the
Office of Communications
at the Library of Congress.
One of my favorite projects
here at the largest library
in the world is managing the
A Book That Shaped Me program
which gives area young
people a unique opportunity
to participate in the
National Book Festival,
which is the library's premier
outreach event celebrating books
and reading.
We're delighted that today's
contest presentation will be
emceed by Eun Yang,
who is no stranger
to the National Book Festival.
[ Applause ]
Eun is an Emmy Award
winning television anchor
for NBC4 Washington.
In addition in anchoring
News4 Today,
she files compelling
community stories about people
and organizations important
to the Washington area
and has been an author
introducer for the book festival
for the past eight years.
She is also the mother of
three and a proponent of books
and reading for young people.
I'm pleased to turn the
program over to Eun.
>> Eun Yang: Thank you Lola.
Lola, thank you so much.
Good morning everyone
and welcome
to the National Book Festival.
It is one of my favorite
events of the whole year.
I clear my calendar
for this event.
I have three kids,
as Lola mentioned.
Two of them are playing soccer.
I brought one of them with me.
And she's right.
I am such a huge fan
of books and reading.
Books take you on adventures.
They help you see the world
through so many different
perspectives.
You don't even have to
leave your house to go
and meet new people
and interesting things.
And one of the best things
about books is they teach you
so much more about other
people and more about yourself,
which is what this essay
contest is all about.
I'm so serious about reading
and I'm such a mean mom that,
of course, there's a
lot of reading to do
at my house over the summer.
And, in fact, I made my
kids write a book report.
No, it was not required by the
school but I wanted to know
that my kids not only
are reading the words,
because they're all voracious
readers and they can eat
up the books, but that
they have an understanding
of what they're reading.
So, sorry guys, it's what I do.
It's because I love you and
it's because I love books
and I know you do too.
So welcome.
It's going to be
such a great day.
Today, Lola and I are joined
on the stage by Jamie Uphold
from the Mensa Education
and Research Foundation,
who also served as one
of the grand prize judges
of this year's contest,
a big job I know.
Very tough.
So many good essays out there.
A Book That Shaped Me was
launched by the Library
of Congress in 2012 with the
DC Public Library and has
since expanded through
the mid-Atlantic region.
The contest asks rising fifth
and sixth graders to reflect
on a book that has
shaped their lives,
influencing the way
they see themselves,
their community, or their world.
Students enter by
writing a one-page essay
that then they submit in person
to a participating public
library in Washington DC,
Maryland, Virginia, Delaware,
Pennsylvania, or West Virginia.
The essays are first
judged by members
of the American Association
of School Librarians,
so these are very
important judges.
Then, the 30 finalists being
honored today were selected
by that panel that
represent these five states
that received essays
over the summer.
I will now go ahead and read the
names of the finalists by state
and then Lola and Jamie
will hand their certificates
as they come up on stage.
And stay up here,
all the finalists,
so we can take a picture
and all that good stuff.
So we're going to start
right here in Washington DC
through the DC public
libraries location.
Those are my libraries.
I love them.
They're just this great resource
of books and information.
And if I mispronounce your name,
please forgive me in advance.
My name is Eun Yang,
so I know what it's
like to have your
name mispronounced
for your entire life
so please bear with me.
All right.
Safya Biswal from
Chevy Chase Library.
She was also the winner
last year so welcome back.
Raphael Fox from the
Tenley-Friendship Library.
Ben Smith from the
Chevy Chase Library.
Brooke Talbott from the Shaw
Watha T. Daniel Library.
Miles Walters from the
Chevy Chase Library.
And the district winner
for 2018 is Zuri Kenyatte
from the Anacostia
Neighborhood Library.
[ Applause ]
Take a picture.
All right.
Congratulations to all of you.
Next, we're going to do
the Maryland finalists.
From the Montgomery County
Public Libraries this year,
we have Brea Ampaw from
the Germantown Library.
Ellyce Butuyan from the
Connie Morella Library.
Grace Hollenbach from
the White Oak Library.
Julliette Mamalian from
the Potomac Library.
Joseph K. Mathew from
the Germantown Library.
And the Maryland winner
this year is Alyssa Yu
from the Germantown Library.
[ Applause ]
Congratulations.
>> Congratulations.
There you go.
[ Applause ]
>> Eun Yang: Congratulations.
All right.
Now Virginia.
Bella DeFilippi could
not be here today
but Bella is one
of the finalists.
Deven Hagen from the
Arlington Public Library.
Eleanor G. Hoopengardner from
the Arlington Public Library.
Julienne Lim from the
Montclair Community Library.
Landon Pollard from
Bedford Central Library.
And this year's Virginia
State winner is Aria Patnaik
from the Reston Regional
Library of Fairfax County.
[ Applause ]
Congratulations.
And next we are going
to announce the finalists
for Delaware.
We have Maggie Clarke-Fields
who could not be here.
Reese Corbett from the
Dover Public Library.
Tianyu Mao from the
Hockessin Library.
Amrita Rai from the
Kirkwood Library.
Michelle Ratanraj from
the Hockessin Library.
And the Delaware winner
is Sarah Jane McMann also
with the Hockessin Library
of New Castle County.
[ Applause ]
Okay.
Congratulations to you.
And lastly but not leastly,
we have the finalists
from Pennsylvania.
Not here today are Sienna
Camlin and Michaela Clement-St.
Louis and Hannah Strawhecker
but congratulations to them.
We do have Brayden Samuelsen
from the Oley Valley Community
Library and Annabelle Troup
from the Quakertown Library and
she was a finalist last year
as well so welcome back.
Congratulations.
And the 2018 Pennsylvania
winner is Tyler Williams
from Spring City Free Library
of Chester County Libraries.
[ Applause ]
Congratulations.
All right.
Can we give one big,
huge round of applause
to our finalists
and state winners?
An amazing job to spend your
time reflecting on a book
that shaped your life, to write
about it, take the initiative
to turn it in, to
be here up on stage.
A big congratulations.
Keep reading those
books and keep writing.
It's so important.
And I will tell you right now,
as a journalist who's been
in this business for a long
time, writing is a part
of every profession
and dream you pursue.
And I know it's tough
but keep that writing up.
I know it's not your favorite.
Reading is so much easier
but keep on that writing.
All right.
So next we're going to hear
from Jamie Uphold, one of A Book
That Shaped Me judges
to introduce the grand
prize winners today.
She is the gifted youth programs
manager for the Mensa Education
and Research Foundation.
She also helped develop
these great children's guides
that you have to the
National Book Festival
which you can pick up today.
So ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Jamie Uphold.
[ Applause ]
>> Jamie Uphold: Thank you, Eun.
It's my pleasure to be here.
To say that books have
been an important part
of my life would be a
grave understatement.
When I was a child growing
up in a low socioeconomic
home, books were my escape.
They were proof that there
was a world -- thank you.
I'm short, sorry.
There was proof that there was
a world out there that was big
and broad and it was full of
hope and people doing things
that didn't happen
where I came from.
So books were my escape.
And because of them and the
love of literature that I grew
from my local library, because
we certainly didn't have money
to go to Barnes & Noble, I
became the person I am today
which loves books and loves
literature and is so proud
and honored to be a part of
the National Book Festival
and the Library of Congress.
It truly is one of
the highlights
of the great things I get to
do for kids all year long.
Being a judge for the Book
That Shaped Me contest is
a nerd's greatest goal.
It truly is.
When they asked me to be a
judge, I thought seriously me?
Do they know who I am?
It has been so fun to watch your
kids express on paper of the joy
and the life changing
moments that they've gotten
from literature of
any type in nature.
And we have a wide and
varied selection of books
that your children choose.
Please take a moment and
join me in giving our thanks
and appreciation to
the other judges.
If you would stand for
the judges of A Book
That Shaped Me contest.
[ Applause ]
As Eun said, it is a tough
job but it's well worth
that struggle to
be able to share
with you today the top three
award winners of the 2018 Book
That Shaped Me contest.
First up, I would like to
welcome Zuri Kenyatte who wrote
about "Lucky Broken
Girl" by Ruth Behar.
Please come on up, Zuri.
Zuri is our third prize --
third place grand prize winner
and the winner from the
District of Columbia.
Zuri is going to share with
us her essay that she wrote
about "Lucky Broken Girl".
Can we borrow a program?
Thank you.
So Zuri wrote a very
personal essay
and it was really very moving.
She'll be sharing that
with us in just a moment.
One of the things that I
loved about her essay is
that she talked so
much about hope.
Miss Zuri, whenever you're
ready to share with us.
>> Zuri Kenyatte: Okay.
So have you ever considered
that one bad decision could
change your life forever?
The book "Lucky Broken Girl"
by Ruth Behar taught
me this lesson.
In the book, an immigrant
Jewish family is involved
in a car accident and
the daughter Ruthie is
severely injured.
Bedridden, Ruthie is
forced to stay in her room,
strung to the ceiling in
a body cast for a year.
She is dependent on
her mom for everything,
even every day necessities like
using the bathroom and bathing.
Even her meals, which had
to be smaller than usual
so she would not outgrow her
body cast, are brought to her.
She is no longer physically
able to go to school,
so the school sends a tutor
to her house to help her keep
up with her classwork.
Life for 10-year-old
Ruthie has changed,
and there isn't much
she could do about it.
This book has many morals and
lessons that stuck with me long
after I finished reading.
The one that had the
greatest impact is
that one bad decision could
change a person's life.
The boys who injured
Ruthie chose to be reckless
and drive drunk, without
considering the lives
of others on the road.
As a result, they not only
severely wounded Ruthie,
but they killed other
drivers and themselves.
This one poor choice
changed a community
of people's lives forever.
A woman is paralyzed for
the rest of her life,
Ruthie loses her independence
and is disabled for a year,
and the boys don't get to
see the other side of 16.
This had a life-long
effect on the families too.
This is tragic, something I
would never want to experience.
"Lucky Broken Girl" taught me
to think about the consequences
of my actions before doing them.
This book also encouraged me
to find a new perspective
when I'm feeling sad.
When Ruthie is depressed
and starts painting the boys
as ghosts, her new neighbor,
Chico, turned her bed
around towards the window to
give her an optimistic view.
Ruthie begins to feel
better instantly.
Instead of being preoccupied
with negative thoughts,
she starts painting
butterflies and flowers.
This taught me that sometimes
all it takes is a different
point of view to
change the scenario.
"Lucky Broken Girl" taught
me that I am in control.
I have the power to determine
my actions and my life.
[ Applause ]
>> Jamie Uphold:
Congratulations, Zuri.
You can certainly see why
she's our third place winner.
I love her comment about one
choice can alter the lives
of a whole community.
Great job, Zuri.
Next up, I'm happy to
introduce our second place --
second place grand prize winner
and the Virginia State
winner Miss Aria Patnaik.
She wrote about "One
for the Murphys".
And I tell you, after
reading her essay,
it made me want to
read this book.
This young lady managed to tell
quite the story with her words
and we'll be happy to hear that
from her in just a few moments.
>> Aria Patnaik: "One for the
Murphys" is a book about family,
strength, heroes,
and most of all,
what it feels like to be loved.
Carley Connors has a
mother who throws parties,
drinks too much alcohol,
and can't bear to say
"I love you" to her
own daughter.
When Carley's abusive stepdad
hurts her and her mother,
Carley is forced into foster
care with the Murphy's,
an affectionate family with a
mother who gives Carley a voice
and makes her realize
what she's been missing.
This book has left an impact
on me for multiple reasons.
First, it taught me that there
is no need to try to be tough
because a little
sensitivity is only natural.
Second, it made me realize
the true value of family
and the love they provide.
And lastly, I learned
what it feels
like to be a castaway
or apart from normal.
This beautiful story provides
a behind the scenes look
at a strong girl with
a sensitive heart.
Growing up with two
older brothers,
people expect me to be tough.
They expect tears to
be a foreign language.
Carley has taught me that
being tough is different
than being strong.
The exact definition of tough
is not easily broken or cut,
while the definition of strong
is accompanied by great power.
This means physically
but also mentally.
You go forth and
face your obstacles.
As Julie Murphy says, "It's
easier to lock yourself away.
It takes strength to face
things that scare you."
I no longer feel like if
I have feelings, I'm weak.
I finally feel free and human.
I've discovered my emotions
and a whole new side of myself.
"One for the Murphys"
left me feeling lucky,
blessed, and thankful.
Oftentimes, I find
myself complaining
about my annoying brothers
or whining to my parents
because something isn't fair.
But after reading this book, I
realized that it's all just part
of the definition of family.
One line from the
book caught my eye.
"The way she reached in,
pulled me out, dusted me off,
and said that I only needed
to be the great person I am."
I realized that that's
exactly what family does.
They take you under their
wing when you're broken,
heal your wound,
and tell you to fly.
So many people don't
get tucked in at night,
so many people don't get to
eat dinner with their family,
and so many people don't get to
play catch with their brothers.
A family is something you
can lean on in times of worry
or sadness, and yet so many
people don't have that.
Carley really highlighted
all the perks of a family
that I see every day
yet take for granted.
All my life, I've
never been the new kid.
I've never felt different
or an outcast.
My whole life is familiar.
I've never moved schools
or houses and that's why
when my parents told me
that for seventh grade,
I'm going to a private school
where I don't know anybody
and where there are
probably some mean girls,
I have to admit I was scared.
This wonderful look
into Carley's thoughts
have shown me what it feels
like to stand apart
from everyone else.
An example from the book is
when Carley says, "I was right
about being a foster kid.
It is humiliating."
When people put labels on
you, it's hard to escape them.
It's hard to know that you're
not like everyone else.
And it takes time to
realize that that's okay.
Carley has taught me that change
is okay and it happens fast,
and though it may be difficult,
you just have to adjust.
Carley is always strong and
stays confident no matter
where she is, and I think
everyone can learn from that.
I've read this book three
times, each at different stages
of my life and each time
this book has helped me
for different reasons.
It has taught me valuable
lessons that help me every day.
Just like Julie Murphy
stuck with Carley,
"One for the Murphys"
stuck with me
and will always stick with me.
When I finished "One for the
Murphys," new thoughts sprung
into my head that I'd
never thought of before.
I thought about why some
parents can handle kids
and some parents can't.
I thought about what I
would do if I had to choose
between a loving and
supportive family
and a neglectful but fun mom.
"One for the Murphys" is about
what strong really means,
always staying confident
and the importance
and many forms of family.
[ Applause ]
>> Jamie Uphold:
Thank you, Aria.
Wonderful job.
And last but not least,
we are happy to welcome
to the stage Mr. Tyler
Williams who wrote
about the Harry Potter
series by J.K. Rowling.
Will you please come
on up Tyler?
Tyler is our first
place grand prize winner
and the Pennsylvania
State winner.
[ Applause ]
>> Tyler Williams: Dear
librarian, let me tell you
about how the Harry Potter
series gave me the strength
to be happy again.
A few years ago I was bullied
in school by my best friends,
and I was too afraid
to tell an adult.
I eventually told
my parents about it
and the threat was gone.
It's a well-known
fact among Potterheads
that Harry Potter
overcame Voldemort.
I kind of thought of it like
this; Harry as the schoolboy
and Voldemort as the bully.
Harry overcame Voldemort
and became a hero.
Albus Dumbledore said in
the book "Harry Potter
and the Sorcerer's Stone, It
takes a great deal of bravery
to stand up to our
enemies, but just as much
to stand up to our friends."
I can relate to this quote
because my bully pretended
to be my friends by
playing games with me
and letting me come
over for a sleepover
but he was a wolf
in sheep's clothing.
The way I was treated
left me in the darkness.
Dumbledore in "Harry
Potter and the Prisoner
of Azkaban" also said,
"Happiness can be found even
in the darkest of times
if one only remembers
to turn on the light."
I needed to get out of the dark,
so I turned on the light
and told my parents.
I was happy again because
I was free from my bully.
By defeating the threat,
I made sure that other
kids didn't share my fate.
The Harry Potter series
helped me find light
in my darkest of times.
It gave me courage to
overcome a bully just
like Harry defeated Voldemort.
My hope is that other kids get
the same courage I did while
reading this amazing series.
>> Jamie Uphold:
Congratulations, Tyler.
A big hand for all of
our finalists and all
of our essay writers this year.
They've done a great job.
[ Applause ]
>> Eun Yang: Wonderful job.
Thank you, Jamie.
Thank you, Lola.
Thank you to the winners.
Thank you for sharing
your stories.
I know that when you write
an essay about a book
that shaped you, you're sharing
such a personal part
of who you are.
And to provide these
beautiful words to share
with everyone else,
it will touch us
and leave us with a gift.
So thank you for doing that.
Thank you for everyone
who contributed.
And I hope you will continue
to write and continue
to enter this essay contest.
Can we just -- one
more round of applause
to indulge me before
you move onto their day.
There are so many
fun things to do here
at the National Book Festival.
To all of you this afternoon,
to all the parents out here
who are supporting your
children in their writing,
to the wonderful families,
the teachers, librarians,
educators who make
this program possible,
thank you from the
bottom of my heart.
I know how hard it is.
It takes a village to foster
these children and raise
up good children, good people
who love to read and write.
Thank you for joining
the Library of Congress
in nurturing the culture
of reading and writing
and treating authors
like they should,
as rock stars in this place.
We honor you and all
your accomplishments
and are really grateful
for your scholarship.
A job well done to
you once again.
Thank you so much.
I love this festival.
I love this event.
Hope to see you back
here next year.
Please spend the day and explore
all these wonderful resources
and books here at
the book festival.
Have a great day.
We'll see you next year.